it's great to welcome to the program
today Lewis Raven Wallace author and
creator of the view from somewhere a
book and podcast about the myth of
objectivity in journalism also
co-founder of press on southern media
collective thanks for your time during
during these strange times I guess I
would say hey yeah of course so to begin
with I will sometimes get these
beautiful emails from people in my
audience who say David I love that you
are not biased in your reporting and
while I will gladly accept any
compliment it concerns me a little bit
from a media literacy perspective
because I do an opinion program I am NOT
doing reporting I'm doing commentary and
the program is very much biased in the
sense that it is my opinion in my
opinion is certainly partisan so can you
start to talk about some of the
categorization of media that needs to be
done and that maybe not everybody is
doing as well as they should
yeah that's such a cool and weird
anecdote that really sounds familiar to
me in that I think there's been this
sort of bending of the concept of media
bias over time to the point that you
know a lot of us think that bias media
is just anything we don't like right or
don't agree with or that doesn't like
vibe with us yes and and so I you know a
part of my sort of thesis has been to
just get rid of this idea that media
bias itself is the problem and accept
that all media in some way is biased
right we have a frame we have an
ideology we have a not you know not
necessarily a partisan political stance
but often that - that we're bringing to
anything that we produce as as
journalists and so it's less about
trying to be unbiased and more about
doing a really rigorous investigation of
what our own biases and perspectives are
and being transparent about those and so
it sounds like you know the
audience members you're hearing from
they trust you yes and they might trust
you in part because of that transparency
and so overall that that's a good thing
but I think an important sort of shift
for us right now is to to move away from
this conflation of objectivity or non
partisanship or being non biased with
being trustworthy because they are not
inherently the same and I think those
concepts have become really muddled in a
way that's actually really damaging can
you talk a little bit about objectivity
versus neutrality which is sometimes a
source of confusion and the way I've
talked about it is I could be neutral on
the issue of whether vaccines cause
autism
or I could be objective which is to
transparently tell you that all the
science tells us that they don't and
that that's the the way I try to explain
it but there's probably a better
umbrella way to talk about that
difference yeah sure so you know I am I
am anti objectivity and neutrality but I
think that there is again a way in which
those concepts have been conflated over
time where objectivity might be narrowly
understood as sort of what you're
talking about
you know rigorous kind of scientific
approach to analyzing the facts in an
honest attempt to reflect the closest
version of truth that we can come up
with right and but more broadly it's
often been interpreted to also mean that
the reporter or the outlet is neutral on
the issue or in some way impartial on
the issue or stands outside of it
in some way and that's been sort of the
journalism school interpretation of
objectivity as well for a long time is
that it's a reflection of neutrality for
me I think even just the the idea that
there is one objective truth
kind of fall apart you know
philosophically at a certain point and
leaves us stuck with some of the same
issues that neutrality does of like how
can we ever fully stand outside of
something and look at it objectively and
I don't think that that's possible but I
do think that rigor transparency being
meticulous being you know striving for
some version of the truth is something
that journalists can and should still
embrace and that that we do need to
separate that out from some sort of
performance of neutrality of performance
of impartiality that has been demanded
of many journalists yet the performative
nature of neutrality is an interesting
way to put it and I think maybe to think
about that a little bit one can
visualize the sort of corporate legacy
media segments about for example climate
change where you have two guests one of
two meaning 50% represents the
scientific view one of to 50% represents
some other view right China created it
it's a hoax or whatever that is a to me
that's performative neutrality in the
sense that it's 50/50 in this very basic
sense but it does not reflect anything
about what's actually happening out
there in the scientific or factual
community
why has corporate media decided to do
that is it as simple as avoiding
criticism more from one political side
than the other or is there more to it
so yes avoiding criticism is one piece
you know I've heard people say that
journalists for all that we are willing
to go after other people are some of the
most thin-skinned folks around which is
neither here nor there to me but but I
think there are larger forces at play
that has always been true in this sort
of performance of objectivity and
neutrality that it originated with a
business model based on advertising so
advertisers wanted to appeal to the
largest possible sort of general
audience but also often an audience that
has money that has resources right so
that might have also translated or still
translate to mean white opera
class audience and so sort of striking a
balance of performed neutrality or
performed impartiality that hits right
at the middle of that target audience is
a priority for advertisers and
underwriters and sponsors that certainly
you know TV news has taken extremely
extremely seriously this performance but
I also wouldn't underestimate you know
it's not pure economic forces there are
also political forces in particular on
the right that have worked very hard for
going on five decades now to sort of
frame the concept of balance in terms of
left right and then delineate a
right-wing perspective that is actually
very very extreme as something normal
and normative and demand that that
perspective be represented in quote
unquote balanced media so the example
that you gave about climate change
climate deniers are this tiny tiny
minority right certainly in the
scientific community but also are a
minority in the general populace in the
United States and so the demand that
they always be represented in a
conversation about climate change is a
huge win for the sort of corporate
right-wing media machine that has pushed
to make that happen and you know this
sort of performance of objectivity
performance of balance and the demand of
that is so dangerous in the hands of
demagogues
and that's what we're dealing with now
right is journalists sitting around
talking about whether or not to say that
Donald Trump is lying because it might
be perceived as partisan to say that he
has lied when he has lied and you know
what could be more toxic to the cause of
truth than that interpretation or that
performance of objectivity and to have
journalists and mainstream newsrooms
sitting around having that conversation
which they are is such a huge win for
far-right activists who want that to be
the debate rather than the truth to be
told and then we debate the real issues
from there yeah as a very brief aside
there's a great book which may not even
be in print any
are called waves of rancor which
describes a lot of the backstory on how
that was built up initially but so you
mentioned that this question of do we
say that Donald Trump is lying or do we
not recently we've seen CNN doing some
sort of live fact-checking
graphically with with notes at the
bottom of the screen during the
coronavirus press briefings can you talk
a little bit about the effect that the
mainstreaming of the term fake news as
sort of as a cudgel has had on
journalism and media yeah sure so you
know the mainstreaming of the term fake
News and Donald Trump's sort of use of
it as you said as a as a cudgel has been
a powerful tool for advancing this sort
of warping of the debate and and this
demand that every discussion be balanced
with with both far-right ideology or in
some cases now just Donald Trump's ideas
whatever they may be but that also that
is part of a long-standing tradition
right in the in the United States that
has always been tied up with racism and
white supremacy and so the example that
I give in my book is this idea of the
lost cause in the Civil War and so you
know the Civil War was at least in part
about ending slavery and slavery was a
terror on the people who were enslaved
you know and I I'm sure I don't need to
tell you that but almost immediately
after the end of the Civil War this sort
of news story was written about who
these white Southerners were who were
fighting for the Confederacy and what
they were about and that they weren't
about slavery or enslavement and all but
you know they just wanted states rights
and they're lost war was this lost cause
of states rights that had nothing to do
with racism and and in the late 1800s
and early 1900s activists for this sort
of lost cause narrative
demanded balance in textbooks right and
demanded that schools in favor of not of
being less bias actually teach this
story that you know slavery had been
this sort of benign thing and that it
wasn't really what civil war was about
and these nice white people just wanted
their states rights and you know and
they were nice to the black people
anyway and all this kind of BS right but
that's like the original fake news like
this sort of you know it's lost cause
and it's biased to teach it as something
that was actually about racism and so
that strategy has been in use by racist
demagogues in the United States since
forever and that's just one example of
it Donald Trump is part of a long
tradition and you know unfortunately has
amassed a great deal of power but he's
not the first racist demagogue to amass
a lot of power
certainly not clearly so in the limited
time we have left I would love to hear
from you what do you see as the lowest
hanging fruit of if we could start
teaching media literacy in seventh grade
which I think would be a great time to
start teaching it three things I think
would be really useful would be teaching
number one understand the primary
purpose of a news source which would
very quickly get you to well if the
primary purpose is to make money that
needs to be included in my analysis
number two understanding whether you're
looking at a primary source or not and
the number three distinguishing between
opinion journalism and news journalism
that's like just an example and there
could be many other examples
what do you see if you get a classroom
of twelve year olds in front of you as
the lowest hanging fruit that would do
the most good
as far as media literacy goes those are
great I love your three points I I think
that my big takeaway not just for
children but for adults and this is
great if we can start a meeting is just
curiosity right that there's always
another question there's always
follow-up so I think we end up being fed
this perception that what you read in
the news or what you hear on the news is
sort of that's it that's the final story
and the the myth of objectivity feeds
into that there are these objective
people out there who are journalists who
just bring you the story and that's
everything that you might
need to know and either you trust them
or you don't but I think all of us right
now really need to be working our muscle
of curiosity and of always asking more
questions and investigating further into
things and essentially sort of become
journalists in a way ourselves certainly
the crisis of Kovan 19 and the pandemic
it has been an opportunity for that
people are seeing in real time how
journalistic fact and truth actually
isn't set in stone it changes pretty
quickly in an environment where even
scientists don't know what this virus is
right and so all of our ability to be
curious and open-minded and to actually
change the way that we think about
something based on new information and
ask new questions overtime to me that's
sort of the core for both people taking
in media and for people producing it is
that we we can all embody more of that
curious journalist or curious scientist
and that a scientist or a journalist the
point of that person is not that they
have the best answers but that they have
the best questions and I think that's
often misunderstood and process is
important right understanding that
because something that was said about
the virus six weeks ago ended up not
being true doesn't mean someone was
necessarily lying it could mean that but
we are sort of iterating science is an
iterative process so is journalism and
understanding that because that's also
weaponized sometimes to say hey the
thing they told us six weeks ago was
wrong
therefore Bill Gates is trying to you
know get a vaccine to sterilize people
or whatever it's all on the table
because something has was corrected the
process part seems so important yeah and
understanding that process of
investigation and inquisitiveness and I
think that's one of the most important
things that we could be teaching in
terms of media literacy is that that's
all that news is right is the best
attempt at providing facts and
information of a group of people who
brought it to you today we've been
speaking with Lois Raven Wallace author
and creator of the view from somewhere a
book and podcast about the myth of
objectivity in journalism so great
having you on I really appreciate your
time
thank you for having me